>> Jesse: ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER FRIENDS OF OURS.
259 DAYS SINCE ECHOED THE WORDS
HUNTER BIDEN.
PUBLISHING A NEW ARTICLE TODAY
TITLED PROSECUTORS ADVANCE TAX
PROBE OF HUNTER BIDEN.
IT CLAIMS THAT THE HUNTER BIDEN
PROBE IS GAINING STEAM.
WHEN IT COMES TO HIS TAXES.
QUOTE:  PROSECUTORS HAVE ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT SEVERAL
COMPANIES ASSOCIATED WITH HUNTER
BIDEN AND ARE EXAMINING WHETHER
HE MOVED FUNDS IN A WAY TO
OBJECT SECURE HIS TAX LIABILITY.
WE HAVE GOT NEW DETAILS
REGARDING QUICK BACKS HUNTER
ALLEGEDLY RECEIVED LIKE THE TIME
A COMPANY LED BY A KAZAKHSTANY
BANKER REMEMBER KAZAKHSTAN WIRED
142-GRAND IT HUNTER'S IT WAS
LATER USED TO BUY HUNTER A
SPORTS CAR A PRITZKER.
HUNTER LATER TRADED FOR FOR A
SILVER PORCH.
NO ONE IN THE BIDEN FAMILY
DRIVES ELECTRIC.
OF COURSE, THAT'S JUST FOR YOU
TO DO.
SOUNDS SKETCHY TO ME.
SOMETHING FEELS WEIRD ABOUT THIS
WHOLE PROBE, RIGHT?
YOU GUYS GET THE FEELING THAT
THIS WHOLE TAX INVESTIGATION IS
JUST A RED HERRING OR A
DIVERSIFICATION DIVERSION AWAY.
IMPLICATE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY LIKE THE BIG GUY.
JIM TRUSTY A FORMER DOJ
PROSECUTOR AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
JIM, WHAT GIVES YOU THE
IMPRESSION THAT THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A CLEAN-UP JOB
GOING ON AT BIDEN'S DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE STARTING
POINT IS THAT IT WAS THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS FOR HUNTER SEVERAL
MONTHS AGO THAT LEAKED OUT THIS
NOTION THAT HE HAD SOME TAX
ISSUES THAT HE HAD 20 CLEAN UP.
I THOUGHT EVEN AT THE TIME THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD DEFENSE
ATTORNEY EUPHEMISM FOR MUCH
BIGGER PROBLEM.
HE HAS A LITTLE TAX ISSUE DON'T
WORRY ABOUT THE VALENTINE'S DAY
MASSACRE.
I THINK FROM THE GET-GO ALL THE
PUBLIC REPORTING WE HAVE SEEN
ABOUT THE LAPTOP ABOUT WIRE
TRANSFERS FROM RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS, KAZAKHSTAN,
EVERYWHERE ELSE, SOUNDS LIKE A
MUCH BIGGER CASE THAN TAX
EVASION.
IT SMELLS LIKE POSSIBLY FOREIGN
AGENT REGISTRATION ACT, FOREIGN
CORRUPT PRACTICES ACT, MONEY
LAUNDERING, I MEAN BIG, WEIGHTY
FEDERAL CHARGES THAT ARE REALLY
INDICATIVE OF A PLAY FOR PAY
KIND OF SCHEME.
MAYBE THE EVIDENCE ISN'T THERE.
BUT IF THE EVIDENCE IS THERE,
AND YOU HAVE THESE TRIAL
BALLOONS ABOUT TAX CASES COMING
OUT, SMELLS LIKE SOMETHING GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF DOJ
CONCLUSION TO COME TO A VERY
SOFT ENDING IN THIS CASE.
>> Jesse: WOULD HUNTER HAVE TO
GO TO PRISON FOR A TAX THIEF.
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
THERE IS ROOM FOR PROSECUTORS TO
BE A LITTLE CREATIVE.
IT'S HARDER WHEN YOU ARE A
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR THAN A STATE
PROSECUTOR, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
BECAUSE OF THINGS LIKE MANDATORY
SENTENCES AND SENTENCING
GUIDELINES THAT ARE DRIVEN BY
LOSS AMOUNT.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALL THOSE
DOLLARS STACK UP TO HIGHER
EXPOSURE FOR HIM.
THERE ARE WAYS TO DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
ABOUT.
AGAIN, I DON'T HAVE PROOF OF
THIS AT ALL.
BUT THE WAY IT'S BEEN DRAGGING
ON AND WAY IT'S BEEN VERY QUIET
AND THE WAY THE TRIAL BALLOON
CAME OUT.
I COULD SEE A QUIET FRIDAY
AFTERNOON ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
HUNTER HAS A MISDEMEANOR PLEA
THAT HE HAS GOT TO ENTER OR A
DEFERRED PROSECUTION AGREEMENT.
THERE ARE WAYS TO EITHER CAP IT
OR ELIM NATIVITY THE ABILITY OF
ANY JUDGE TO PUT PRISON ON THE
TABLE.
>> Jesse: HUNTER, AFTER ALL OF
THIS COULD END UP WITH NO JAIL
TIME.
DO YOU THINK THAT FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS -- I KNOW THIS IS
COMING OUT OF DELAWARE, ARE
GETTING PRESSURE FROM MAIN
JUSTICE?
>> YEAH.
NO WAY TO KNOW.
I GUESS THE WAY I WOULD PHRASE
IT, JESSE.
THERE MAY NOT BE PRESSURE I'M
NOT IN LOVE WITH HOW THE FBI HAS
CONDUCTED ITSELF UNDER CHRIS
WRAY.
I DON'T SEE A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE POLITICIZATION THEY
HAD WITH COMEY AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT DOING FEDERAL SEARCH
WARRANTS FOR DIARIES.
THAT'S UNHEARD OF.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS THAT THE
INVESTIGATING AGENCY HERE HAS A
LITTLE POLITICAL EDGE TO IT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE LEADERSHIP.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY HAS KEPT THEIR
POSITION BECAUSE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS ACTUALLY
NOT UNHEARD OF.
THAT'S TYPICAL WHEN THERE IS A
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
I THINK IT'S A REAL INTEGRITY
TEST FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT'S THE GUY THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO SIGN OFF ON ANYTHING.
WHETHER IT'S A VERY STRONG
INDICTMENT, A NON-PROSECUTION
AGREEMENT, A DEFERRED
PROSECUTION AGREEMENT.
A SOFT PLEA GIVING HIM, YOU
KNOW, BASICALLY NO JAIL.
ANY OF THOSE THINGS ARE GOING TO
MAKE THEIR WAY UP TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND BOY, IT'S A
HUGE INTEGRITY TEST UNLIKE
ANYTHING WE HAVE SEEN IN
PRESIDENTIAL HISTORY.
>> Jesse: WELL, WE HAVE HAD A
GUEST ON LAST WEEK WHO TOLD US
THEY THOUGHT THAT HUNTER WAS
GOING TO GO TO PRISON FOR A
WHILE UNLESS HIS DAD PARDONED
HIM AND NOW YOU ARE SAYING THAT
HE MIGHT GET AWAY SCOT-FREE AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK.
I'M JUST WONDERING WHERE THAT
DIAMOND IS THAT THAT CHINESE
TYCOON GAVE HIM.
WE WILL HAVE TO KEEP FOLLOWING
WHERE THE LEADS TAK